cologne is in carnival fever carnival in
the summertime doesn't Carnival season
usually kick off on the 11th of November
but then in cologne there's always a
reason to party why carnival in the
summer because we can't wait until
november until winter either got stuck
with sure I always say either you've got
it or you don't this is the real
carnival here in Cologne you can finally
dress up in things you can't wear in
winter everyone's expected to get made
up even me the reporter
the band Kassala is also here Carnival
season is an especially lucrative time
for the musicians
fishman around half of our gigs are
carnival gigs they're just normal rock
concerts so even those who don't want to
dress up are welcome at our concerts
everywhere I look I see tourists some
three million flock to Cologne each year
and their numbers are growing and
there's one industry that caters to them
prominently here the fashion industry I
never knew Cologne had so many boutiques
and Studios the wondrous label uses
vintage fabrics some of which date from
the 1930s some of the garments have this
used look shirts sell for around 90
euros the clothes here are one-offs or
belong to small collections and
naturally they're all made in Cologne
yeah we always work in these little
flaws which aren't really flaws at all
this is quality tailoring but it should
look like a favorite piece that's been
hanging in your closet for 20 years oh
why are you in Cologne not Berlin or
Dusseldorf crying alone is our home our
goods are made here we feel like we
belong here this is our city people from
Cologne are free spirits who like it
when things are laid back in the city's
hip belgian quarter I visit Damon Tejada
she was born in Turkey and came to
Germany as a child four years ago she
started her own business over 60,000
Turks live in cologne and are part of
its success story de menthe aha for
example has just opened her third shop
Colonel people don't usually associate
cologne with fashion should they as a
dusker cologne is an unsung fashion
metropolis in Germany I mission moda
metal pole people always think of the
DISA Dolph of your or nowadays Berlin
for Hamburg with its elegant ladies or
Munich with its chic Italian flair
munchen italienisch Shanga ho but
cologne has a very colorful fashion
scene
there they are bunt escena haha oh yeah
yeah I mean it cologne is Germany's
fourth largest city and popular with
students but right now i'm going to the
largest Gothic church in Northern Europe
the Cologne Cathedral 157 meters high
and more than seven hundred and sixty
years old